in light of digital privacy concerns
many apps and websites are updating
their Terms of Service have you noticed
this okay I'm just gonna keep talking
I'm discussing the terms users must
accept before using an app before you
accept using an app you have to accept
their terms and services now most people
just click agree without reading the
fine print all of us do that you're
probably not aware of what you've agreed
to so as a public service I'm just gonna
take a second and look at a few right
now so you know what you're signing up
for for example the ride share app uber
when you click agree on uber you agree
to give creepy drivers five stars and a
tip because they know where you live
that's simply how it works
yes the geology app ancestry the
genealogy app ancestry when you click
agree on ancestry you agree not to ask
why your grandfather and your
great-uncle seem to be the same guy
an agreement the food delivery app hosts
mates if you click agree on post mates
you agree to pay $45 for some chicken
fingers and an upside-down container of
salad
the GPS shortcuts app Waze when you
click agree on ways you agree to risk
your life making a left turn across six
lanes of traffic to shave maybe 12
seconds off your commute maybe 12 Angry
Birds
when you click agree on Angry Birds you
agree that until you about a week ago
you had a flip phone and finally yeah
and finally the Web MD app when you
click agree on Web MD you agree that you
have either a malignant brain tumor or
just bad allergy
[Applause]
you